[MUSIC PLAYING]
BOB OMER: Well, thanks.
Thanks for having us today.
We're actually excited to
be here, and appreciate
the opportunity to come in and
tell you a little bit what Defy
Ventures Colorado is about.
I think the place to
start is entrepreneurship.
And you might think
to yourself, well,
why are we talking about
entrepreneurship with work
that you do in prisons?
And our belief is that
entrepreneurship is actually
one of the keys to giving
people a second chance who
are incarcerated within
the state of Colorado
as well as in the United States.
And so you might think
to yourself, well,
what does that mean
to be an entrepreneur?
How are you teaching
entrepreneurship?
And I think what we
have found the best way
to do that is just to give you a
short glimpse into what happens
into one of our prisons.
And so I'm just going to play
for you a short video that--
it's about 60 seconds long.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Colorado should
be the worst place
to commit a violent
crime, and the best
place to get a second chance.
I think what Defy does,
it defies the odds,
it defies the traditional way
of looking at rehabilitation,
and kind of creates its own
energy, its own hurricane,
a possibility.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
My goodness, this
is a happy day.
We're showing that we can
become more than our past.
[END PLAYBACK]
BOB OMER: So what do you think?
Maybe not what you expect
to be happening in prisons,
particularly in our more secure
prisons within the state.
And you probably got
a sense from watching
that video the energy,
but also the passion that
came from the
community, maybe even
recognized a few of the faces.
And part of the reason we love
coming out to the community,
particularly here in Boulder,
to talk with everyone
is Defy was very much born out
of the passion for innovation
here in Boulder.
And I don't know if
anybody recognizes,
obviously, we have the
former governor up here,
Brad Feld, a couple of other
people from the Foundry Group.
And the Foundry Group
were really the proponents
to bring Defy
Ventures to Colorado,
that passion for
entrepreneurship,
that passion of bringing
the community together
to try to solve one
of society's problems.
And so, our goal here today
is to spend the next 10 to 15
minutes to tell you a little
bit about Defy Ventures
Colorado, the kind of the
what, the why, and the how.
And I'm going to have our
program manager, Stacey Putka,
come up and do that.
And before we move
to that, I just
want to encourage
everybody in the room--
our goal today is to make this
as interactive as possible.
And so we'll have plenty
of time for Q&A at the end.
But if anybody
has any questions,
feel free to ask
them at any point.
When we get done with our
overview of the program
from Stacey, we've actually
got a very diverse panel here
who brings quite
differing perspectives
from the incarcerated sector
in terms of talking about Defy
the program, but
more importantly,
how we can all come together
to solve this issue.
And so with that, I'm
going to turn it over
to Stacey, who will come up
and talk about the program.
STACEY PUTKA: So,
Defy Ventures Colorado
was born out of the idea
that we lack some things.
We think about our
past, we can all
think of something that
we've done that we're not
necessarily proud of.
And we believe in second
chances and providing
those second chances
through entrepreneurship.
We do that in a
really unique way
that most programs
that work with people
with criminal histories
aren't able to do,
that we're very lucky to do.
So we start inside
prisons, and we
provide an eight-month long
program called "CEO of Your New
Life" where individuals
engage in character
development, career readiness,
and entrepreneurial education.
So you can see up here from
are very complicated program
diagram, that we start
inside the facilities,
and then we continue to work
with people once they are
released from incarceration.
There are a few things
that we do with them
when they are released.
One is they go through what's
called "Pathways to Re-entry"
where they basically get
stable in the community--
housing, health care,
jobs, financial stability--
so that they don't need to
revert to old ways of thinking
or being.
They're stable.
Once they're stable
within their communities,
they can go into our business
incubator, where they then
learn to actually start and
run their own small business
that they planned and
worked on while they
were currently incarcerated.
So you can see
that our mission is
to transform the lives of
people with criminal histories
along the
entrepreneurial journey.
The reason that we do
this is because America
has a prison crisis.
We have 5% of the
world's population,
but 20% of the world's
incarcerated population.
30% of 23-year-olds
have a criminal history.
So whether you're watching
this on your computer,
or you're sitting in the
audience, how many of you
can think of something
really stupid
that you did before
the time you were 23?
We think that's really early
to start writing people off.
Of people who go to
prison, 67% of them
are rearrested and
go back to prison
within three years
of being released.
In Colorado, it's 45%.
Having a criminal history makes
it significantly difficult
to get and maintain employment.
People who have a
criminal history
have employment rates that are
27% lower than other people.
And by checking the box,
"I have a felony history"
on a job application
reduces their chances
of getting a callback
from an employer by 50%.
So, not only do we have a
program in prison that's
eight months long where
they work on character
development, entrepreneurship,
and career readiness,
we bring in volunteers to
help them along that journey.
So last year alone, we brought
in over 340 volunteers.
We brought in 452 Googlers
in our counterpart
in northern California.
So, Googlers have been involved
in this for a very long time
in northern California.
And we're looking
to get Googlers here
in Colorado involved as well.
The secret sauce to what
works, why this program works,
is the community that we
build around the people who
are currently incarcerated.
It's very rare for someone
who's incarcerated to see anyone
else other than correctional
officers and their family
members.
So to have these
opportunities to talk
about character development,
career readiness, and business
with top executives and
empathetically-minded people
from the community allows them
an extra advantage to success
once they reintegrate
into society
that most people don't have.
So on that theme of building
community and having
this community travel with
the people in our program
from the inside to the outside,
I'm going to bring Bob back up,
and he's going to introduce
some of our key stakeholders
in the community who are going
to give you guys a little bit
more information.
BOB OMER: So, why don't we start
with-- go down the line, just
start with a brief intro.
A lot of it'll come out as
we go through our panel,
but maybe spend one or two
minutes just telling us
a little bit about yourself,
and why you're here today.
And we'll start next
to me with Brandon.
BRANDON HAGANS: So my
name is Brandon Hagans.
I'm the Gang
Intelligence supervisor
at Colorado State Penitentiary.
Colorado State
Penitentiary is where
we keep probably the
most dangerous offenders
in the State of Colorado.
And we were actually
the first facility--
were we the first facility?
We were the first facility
to give us this program a go.
Initially when we were told
that they were going to come in,
and this is what
they wanted to do,
it scared us just because of
our [INAUDIBLE] population.
So we sat down, and
we picked 20 guys
that we thought we
could put in a room
without them trying
to kill each other
and keeping these
wonderful individuals safe.
And it worked out.
And from that initial
class, just the amount
of guys that are
wanting to get into this
and participate in it, I
mean, it's just been amazing.
Our violence within our facility
has dropped off drastically.
I can't give you
exact percentages,
but I can tell you
being in there day
in and day out that
our violence has
dropped because these guys
want to get in this program.
They want to do better for
themselves and learn something.
BOB BUCHOLZ: Hello,
my name's Bob Bucholz.
I work for the Colorado
Department of Corrections.
I work at the Arkansas
Valley Correctional Facility.
That's about two
hours east of Pueblo.
And Defy fire has--
from what we can tell,
has made a huge difference
in our population as
far as having offenders
involved in the program have
bled over to them talking
to staff, which before--
I mean, that's kind of the no
man's land as far as offenders
wanting to talk to staff.
And Defy, when they're
working on their programs,
the offenders are
working on their plans,
they end up coming and
asking staff for input,
which is really neat.
It's a really neat
opportunity for us and them.
RONNIE MADRID: Hi, my
name is Ronnie Madrid.
And I am an entrepreneur
in training,
graduate from the first class
in Colorado State Penitentiary.
I agree, it's been amazing.
I had to work my butt off
to get into that class.
And it absolutely
changed the path
that I was taking before, simply
because the people with Defy
who came in, as well as this
gentlemen right here, they
are the first ones probably
throughout my whole life who
actually gave me a chance.
And seeing that, I wanted to
do better so I could be better.
And I've been able to
present myself to the world
while I'm working on
being towards my best.
And it's because of the things
that I have around me now,
the people that I
have around me now,
from what I learned about myself
in transition from being a gang
member and a drug
dealer, somebody
who made terrible choices
throughout his life
to a single father
who wants to learn how
to cook so my kids don't have
to eat Hot Pockets anymore,
Fruity Pebbles.
And they help me
when I'm out here.
Izzy's always asking if she
can help me with anything.
It really does extend
from the inside
out when not a
lot of programs do
that are involved with the
Department of Corrections.
Thank you.
TOM WYMAN: Hey, I'm Tom Wyman.
I'm a volunteer
from the community.
I'm on the Defy Ventures
Colorado Advisory Board.
I used to work at Google,
Boulder Office for six years
a while back.
Now I'm with a company
called Building Ventures.
But, yeah I've been a
volunteer with Defy Colorado
for about a year.
First saw it from a
Brad Feld blog post.
He was talking about his
experience in prison and how--
I mean, the enthusiasm just
completely came through
in the blog post.
And the end, after describing
his whole day and what
it was like, he had Bob's
email at the bottom.
And so I e-mailed Bob
to find out what's
the story with this thing.
And he, and Stacey, and
I went out to lunch.
And then Stacey, Izzy,
and I went in to prison.
And yeah, I lost track at how
many times have gone back.
It's been a wonderful thing.
TRAVIS TAYLOR: Oh, me?
My name is Travis Taylor.
And that wonderful,
beautiful human being
that you see to my
left and your right
with the long hair
and glasses, he and I
are four years and
four hours apart.
He is my younger brother.
His name is Darius Taylor.
I am the very,
very proud brother
of an Arkansas Valley
Correctional Facility
EIT and graduate.
I met Bob at my little
brother's graduation.
And to say the meeting
was life changing
does not do it justice.
Defy, in order for it to
reach the communities the way
that we expected, we will
need people such as yourselves
to see what we see.
And part of that is
going to be today.
And I hope you become as excited
about joining Defy and having
it do what it did in my life
and in my family's life for you
and yours.
So, I thank you
all for being here.
BOB OMER: That's great.
So we've got about
as diverse as you
can get in this issue, two
people who actually work
inside the prison,
somebody who was in prison,
and then two volunteers, and
one who brings the family
perspective that's there.
The question I would like to
go to-- and I guess I'm going
to do this because the two
people who drove the farthest--
Bob you drove, what, about three
and 1/2 hours to come up here
for an hour, and Brandon
about two and 1/2 hours is--
why did you do that?
I mean, why did
you get in the car
and drive up here, and come
here and talk, and explain
the perspective from
your standpoint?
Bob, do you want to go first?
BOB BUCHOLZ: Sure.
I made the trip because Defy
has, like I stated earlier,
has made a huge impact for
us on the prison population.
It was actually impressive
on the first day
they came in there, we
had over 100 offenders.
And when they started
off the program there,
it was amazing how they could
control the offender population
in that room.
The respect that happened
between the volunteers
and the actual offenders in
the room was just incredible.
And it was really nice for us
to see us staff working there
because we're there to help,
we're not there to punish.
The courts have
already done that.
Our job is to help out
for them to be successful.
And it's great because when
you looked at Defy's mission
statement, it actually
leads right into our mission
statement, which is a successful
reentry of all offenders
back into society.
So it really matches up well.
That's worked very well.
It keeps them busy.
You can walk through at
night, do cell checks,
look in the doors,
they're actually
working on their business plan.
They take it serious.
So that's been a really,
really good program.
And we believe in it.
BOB OMER: Brandon,
what about you?
BRANDON HAGANS: So for me coming
from CSP and just the clientele
that we have there,
when we initially
walked these guys into the
room to start this program,
usually when they leave they day
hall, they're fully restrained.
Wrist, ankles, they've
got handcuffs everywhere.
And this was the first time we
ever took these individuals,
and put them in
our visiting room,
and took the cuffs off
with a bunch of volunteers.
And it was kind of hairy.
It didn't feel right
for the environment.
But once they got rolling
with the program, I mean,
these guys were standing
up hugging each other.
And the whole time I'm thinking,
please don't hurt anybody.
But this program gave them hope.
With the volunteers coming
in, a lot of these guys,
they don't get
family to come in.
They don't have much
communication at all.
And when the volunteers
come in, they
give them a sense
of being, a sense
of hope, a sense of purpose.
And it's just amazing to
see their faces light up,
the changes they make, their
demeanor, their attitudes,
it's just amazing to
watch these guys change.
BOB OMER: Ron, I want to direct
this next question to you
because I think what would
be beneficial for the people
here in the room and
watching on video
is to understand that that
initial engagement point,
right?
We didn't talk about it
earlier, but real quickly
the Defy program is an
eight-month program.
I would describe
it as intensive.
Obviously, we'd love your
opinion on that an hour
or two a day to stay up with it.
Why did you come
into the program?
And then what kept you going
through those eight months
because obviously, there were
the ups and downs of life
that were happening as
you went through that.
RONNIE MADRID: OK, Bob.
I came into the program because
it's an entrepreneurship
program.
I was in prison for
a distribution case.
I gangbanged my whole life.
I lost my wife 18 months
ago to a drug overdose.
She started using drugs, the
same drugs that I was selling.
She lost her life
eventually after it.
Our kids were separated.
I'm still fighting
for my kids right now.
And so when that stuff
started to happen to me,
and I seen where
my life was headed,
I realized that it was time for
me to absolutely make a change,
or I was in a die in prison.
And at that point, the
most important thing to me
was family.
And I have a job right now.
I'm in a halfway house.
I got out December 26.
And it's the third job that
I've ever had in my life.
But the entrepreneurship
program, when I went in there,
and we were working on our
resumes, and our job skills,
I realized that I have
marketing, distribution,
quality control--
[LIGHT LAUGHTER]
--customer service.
I have all of these--
I have all of these
skills that I can tran--
that are transferable
skills that Stacey has--
you know, she's my [INAUDIBLE].
You could do this.
And I realized I
absolutely can, and I will.
Right now, I'm trying to get it
approved with the halfway house
for me to go to Metro State.
I want to go for
organizational communication
so I can be a
mentor, a consultant.
I want to be able to
just pass the buck.
I also want to look into some
certification for addictions
counseling simply because I've
been on both sides of the dope
game.
I've been in the streets.
I was a gang leader
from my neighborhood,
and I walked away.
And that was the scariest--
to walk away from the streets,
it was the scariest thing
that I've ever done in my
life because I had made it
through the ups and the downs.
The Colorado State Penitentiary,
I don't know if you are aware,
but it's the absolute worst
that the State of Colorado
has to offer as far as
punishment minus the death
penalty.
You go to prison--
you get in trouble,
you go to prison.
You get in trouble in
prison, you go to the hole.
You keep getting in
trouble, they send your butt
to Colorado State Penitentiary.
And it's a war zone.
It's a war zone.
They let us out for breakfast.
And everybody's
running into the shower
so they could go get their
shower because we might have
been locked down for six, seven
days because of a stabbing,
or an assault, or
something like that.
And as soon as three
or four minutes later,
it's doo, doo, doo,
first responders.
And it's literally a war zone.
But when Defy came, and
we were ready to go,
every Tuesday I
was like, I'm gone.
I'm leaving this place.
I'm getting some sanity
on [INAUDIBLE],, some peace
for a while because everybody
in that program was like,
this is not what we're doing.
This is what we're
doing for us tomorrow.
We can leave all the
politics and all the prison
stuff back at the house.
And everybody did it.
I don't know how
these people did it.
I don't know Bob, and
Stacey, and the volunteers,
and everybody came
in, but they did it.
I got seriously-- this man
right here said they do walks,
and people are doing
their homework.
And they're big books like this.
And I would literally
stay in my room
some days for two or
three hours thinking
about what I need to
say for this answer
because it affected me because
I really wanted that change.
And these people really put
forth the effort, and the time,
and were patient with us.
They literally laid on the
floor with us and were like,
we're here.
We've got something if you
want to accept it, fine.
You now what I mean?
We're willing to give it
to you all the way through.
And they follow through.
It started on the inside.
I came out, and this is the
best I've ever done in my life.
This is the best I've
ever done in my life.
I know for sure I'll be a
multimillionaire in five
years-- legit, legit, legit,
legit, seriously legit.
BOB OMER: But that's great.
I think that's
interesting, right?
As we go down the line, we
hear the impact in prisons.
We hear the impact
Ron in your life.
But I want to switch to
hear about the impact
that Tom and Travis have
seen both from themselves
and the community.
But I think Travis, I want
to start with you as I also
talk a little bit
about the impact you've
seen in your brother, Darius,
who's at Arkansas Valley.
TRAVIS TAYLOR: So, usually I
tell the story about my brother
and how he wound up in prison.
But listening to that, I want
to back up just a second.
So when my brother first went
to prison, the first time,
it was in 2001--
or 2000.
He went from 2000 to 2005.
He's in the federal
penitentiary,
and he was prosecuted
under something
called Project
Exile, where if you
carry a gun, an illegal gun
in the State of Colorado,
you automatically got a
five-year federal prison
sentence.
Don't pass go.
Don't collect $200.
Don't say hi to your momma.
You're gone.
My brother was 19 years old.
My brother went to
prison at 19 weighing--
he was 5'4"--
5'5" weighing 140 pounds.
My brother came out of
prison weighing 215 pounds.
And he looked like one
of them action figures
from Batman or something.
Now, for the rest of
us, we're like, oh, OK.
Well, my brother stayed for
exactly six weeks, six weeks.
That second time, they sent
my brother away for 44 years.
Let that sink in your
head for a second--
44 years.
The problem with
that is my brother
wasn't doing 44 years alone.
My mother, myself, my father,
his sister, nieces, nephews,
we all got that 44-year
prison sentence.
We all got the five-year
We all got the
six-week furlough.
So my brother never
understood this concept.
No matter how many times
we tried to talk to him,
there was a period where
I didn't write, speak,
or talk to my brother.
He'd write letters,
I'd take the letters--
and someday if I ever see
y'all again, I'll show you--
I kept the box.
And y'all didn't know this.
I kept the box of
the unopened letters
because I didn't feel
he deserved my energy
or time to read another
excuse, another it
won't happen again
because it kept happening.
Even when he was in
prison, it kept happening.
Then Defy comes along.
And I'm going to kind
of speed it up now.
Defy comes along.
And his entire thought pattern
of how he processed information
changed.
The way he carried
himself changed.
The way he started
talking changed.
He said something
that I had never heard
him say before in a visit.
And he goes, I did it.
Excuse me, what, huh, what?
He said I did it.
I did everything
they said I did.
I did it all.
I made that mistake,
but that was me then.
That's not me now.
So while you're here on this
visit, you have a choice.
You can keep looking
at me for who I was,
or you can look at me for
who I'm trying to become.
I have seen my brother
virtually every weekend
since that meeting.
I was proud to go
to his graduation.
I walked up to Bob, because they
don't-- you weren't supposed
to get up and walk around
because it's a prison,
and you weren't
supposed to be moving.
But the guy that saw
me was like, hey,
can I go talk to this guy?
And I'm pointing at Bob.
And he's like, ah,
I ain't see you.
So I jump up, and
I run over to Bob,
and he's in the middle
talking to somebody.
And I'm trying to
keep it together,
but I can't stop crying.
And it wasn't sadness,
it was absolute elation
because I had never
seen my brother graduate
from anything but
a prison sentence
to another prison sentence.
That's all I had seen.
And now, I see my brother
walking around with his chest
out, his hands up.
And he's recognizing
not only what he was,
but who he can become.
And I walked up to
Bob, and I told him,
I said, Bob, listen,
I own a company.
It's a finance company.
I make a little bit of
money, not like this,
but I make some money.
And I said, Bob,
whatever you want,
I'll write you a check, whatever
you need, whatever you need.
He was like, I don't really
know you, but OK, cool.
And I'm sitting there
like, I love you people.
And he's like, I just met you.
I was like, no, no,
I still love you.
And he and Stacey gave
myself and a gentleman
in the back there
who's my business
partner, his name's Gil Datz,
and a young lady in their named
Kayla [? Goley-- ?] she just
got married everybody, Kayla
[? Goley-- ?] and they
decided to help me
with Bob, and Stacey, and Izzy.
And listening to you,
I can only imagine
what that felt like
walking out the door
and changing your
life for the good.
These two gentlemen who, we're
not go knock them for they
do for their living,
because they have a purpose,
but I'm certain they're happy
to hear that they will never
meet you in their professional
life again, right?
And that's really
what this is about.
That's what I guess you
wanted me to tell you.
I'm not going to bore you
with all the family history.
But the bottom line
is my little brother
is now a different person.
And it would have
never happened--
listen to me very closely.
They say never use
the word never.
It would have never happened
without Bob and Stacey.
My brother came from
a two-parent home.
My dad was in the military.
My mom was a
registered dietitian.
We all went to college.
He got a football scholarship.
There was absolutely no reason
for him to ever join a gang,
let alone put that monstrosity
that's on his back.
But he did.
And now he's understanding
that he did not
belong in prison except to learn
the life he had was a blessing.
You've learned the life
that you have is a blessing.
No matter what
environment you were in,
Defy gave that
back to my family.
And as I told you
then, I'll tell you now
for the rest of my
life, whatever you need,
whenever you need it, you call.
And I hope you do.
And I thank Defy for giving
my family an opportunity
to have my brother back.
And I thank you for
all of your hard work.
Stay on his ass
while you're in there
and bring my brother home
because I once he comes home,
the only time we'll
ever think about you
is when we see you at Defy
event because you will never
see him in your
professional capacity again.
And I thank you, and Defy,
and Stacey for all of that.
And I hope all of you join
us with working with Defy.
I really do.
It'll change your lives
because it changed ours.
BOB OMER: Well what-- so let me
just jump in because what are
we really saying here, right?
I mean we've--
I mean, let's just reframe it.
We don't have a shortage of
people in prisons, right?
programs in prisons, right?
These aren't one-off
situations with Ronnie,
with Darius, et
cetera, that's here.
I have my belief of what we're
talking about here, which
is this issue of volunteerism
and collective community
impact.
But I'm actually
interested following
on Travis' point, Tom,
is to hear from you.
What's been your
experience as a volunteer?
I mean, you didn't--
I'm assuming you'd never
been into prison before,
before you came in with
Defy for the first time.
Before we talked about,
what, 340-plus volunteers
came in 2018 who made the two
and 1/2 hour drive from Boulder
and places.
I mean, how many times have
you been to prison with us?
TOM WYMAN: I'm not sure.
I've sort of lost count.
BOB OMER: Yeah, I mean it
easily has to be about five,
I mean, at this point.
TOM WYMAN: Yeah, I think
it's double digits.
BOB OMER: But is it
from your perspective?
You don't come with Travis'
background of having a loved
one who had been in prison.
What is it from
that perspective,
from the volunteer's
perspective, you think,
that makes it work?
TOM WYMAN: Well, I think
what motivates you to go in,
and then what your
experience is once you're in
are sort of two
different stories.
And I think the thing that
motivated me to go in is--
that's probably a little fuzzy.
As I get older, I'm more
curious about different people's
experiences, more maybe
aware of some of the benefits
I've had in my life.
But mostly, I'm kind of
a sucker for a cause.
And I didn't know if
this was going to be--
I didn't know this was
going to be the cause.
I just thought it was an
interesting thing to do.
And so I talked
to Bob and Stacey,
and they made it sound great.
And so I hopped in the car
and drove to Arkansas Valley.
And it's a long drive.
And it's a long time
to think about, wow,
I'm going to walk into a prison.
I never really been in a prison.
Maybe that's a little bit
out of my comfort zone.
Maybe I-- I wonder why I
signed up for this exactly.
And so you go in-- or at least
I went in with Stacey and Izzy
that first time.
And it was to speak to a class--
every week there's a class
with a different topic.
And I think I was talking
about sort of personal brand,
and raising money, and
that sort of thing.
And I walked in the room, and
all these guys wearing green
just sort of made a
beeline right for me.
And everyone had a giant grin on
their face and their hand out.
And it wasn't that polite, well,
it's very nice to meet you.
It was like they were
a psyched to see me.
And I wasn't exactly sure why
they were psyched to see me,
but it was like this
instant acceptance
that you don't get when
you just sort of walk
into a business meeting.
And so that felt--
I mean, I was immediately
at feeling comfortable
with the whole thing.
And I got on with
my presentation.
And we were talking about
ways to fund your company.
So we're talking about
bootstrapping, our friends
and family around, or angel,
or venture, or whatever.
And somebody raised
their hand and said, hey,
what about a bank loan?
And I started to
answer and realized,
I've never really been involved
in one of those transactions
with a startup with a bank loan.
And so I started to explain
that this isn't something
I have a lot of experience in.
And this guy in the back row,
one of the EITs in the back row
raises his hand.
He's like, excuse me, the
first company that I started,
actually we started
with a bank loan.
I could address
this if you like.
And this guy gave a great
explanation of how that works.
And it was at that moment that
I realized, wow, I totally
sold these guys short.
And as you listen to
the questions they asked
and the points they
made, there were
a bunch of very sharp,
super-motivated people
in that room.
And you realize,
oh my gosh, there
is a ton of potential
locked up in this space.
I think the other thing
Bob that totally motivated
me was the way these guys
make themselves vulnerable.
I mean, part of every
session starts with--
commitments, thank you--
commitments and affirmations.
And one of them is, "I
will be vulnerable."
And you just know
from life experience
that you can have so much better
conversation with someone--
you can learn so
much more from them,
and they can get more from
you if you allow yourselves
to make yourself vulnerable.
But if you think
about it in prison,
that's probably the last
thing that you want to be
is vulnerable?
Yeah.
And so the fact that they
could come into this room
and have so much trust in
each other and the volunteers,
and they can just
flips that switch
and be completely open and
vulnerable for a couple hours,
and then go back to the
regular life and turn that off,
I mean, to me that
just showed they're
willing to make a giant
leap to make this work.
That can not be an easy thing.
And I think that was one of
the things that partly sold me
on the effort that
they put into it.
But partly just made it so
much more rewarding for me
and made it such a privilege
to spend time with these guys
and get to know
them a little bit.
BOB OMER: Yeah, I think
that's an interesting point
on the vulnerability.
And Ron, I want to come back
to you and your experience
being on the inside.
We use the word EIT,
entrepreneur in training,
which everybody who comes
into our program, that's
what their title is.
What was the impact
of that volunteers,
of those volunteers coming into
the facility week after week?
Not only how did it tie
into your personal journey,
but how did it tie into that
aspect of vulnerability,
of people feeling like
they can kind of not
let their guard down for
lack of a better term,
but to work on what's
important in terms of making
transformational change?
RONNIE MADRID: Well, the
thing is everybody in prison
wants to change.
Every single
person, I don't care
who it is, everyone
is tired of it,
especially repeat offenders.
I'm a repeat offender.
I actually do know your
brother [INAUDIBLE]..
TRAVIS TAYLOR: Yeah.
RONNIE MADRID: We were--
we started out together at
the same time in prison.
And he had just
got out the feds.
And I was on my
way back to prison.
We were in Denver
County together.
We used to work-- that's
a good friend of mine.
I just haven't seen
him in forever.
But especially repeat
offenders, we're always like,
I'm so tired of this.
I'm tired of it.
But there is never
anything available to us
simply because of our
jackets, of our background,
of who we are on paper.
The recidivism rate
stays high because nobody
knows who we are, because
nobody gives us a chance.
Up until very
recently, I start--
I grew up in the
juvenile system and spent
about 13 and 1/2 years of my
adult life in the adult system.
And I take full responsibility
for the choices that I made.
And sentences were deserved.
They were deserved because I
was making poor life choices,
and I was where I needed to be.
Going back to what I
said in the beginning,
everybody wants to change.
Everybody wants to change.
And even when we speak
up, and we're like,
I want to do this no more,
up until very recently,
the Department of
Corrections hasn't been
the Department of Corrections.
It never corrected behavior.
It was a Department
of Confining.
They would lock us up.
And CSP, they'd
just opened it up.
It's a closed facility now.
But I did six years in
solitary confinement
because of the choices that
I made inside of prison.
And nobody cared about what I
wanted to do because I was just
like everybody else.
Like I said, everybody
inside wants to change.
And they speak it.
I don't want to do this no more.
The fact of the matter is,
it's another world inside.
Being vulnerable
is the last thing
that you want to be in prison.
You have to be an
alpha male or you're
going to be somebody's something
that you don't want to be.
Going to be the victim
of something or somebody.
And when Defy would bring
their volunteers in, all of us,
we couldn't wait to
go to class on Tuesday
because it was five hours
away from the craziest stuff
that you could imagine.
You never realized what
people could do to people
when you're in a war zone.
And you go into them classes,
and these people right here,
they would come up, and they
didn't look at you like that.
They wanted to hear
what you actually
had to say about your
business, or about your day,
or about your family, about
what you wanted to do.
And they really
wanted to help you.
Every conversation
that I had with anybody
as far as a volunteer
that came up,
they've held true to their word.
They seriously have
held true to their word.
And I feel like the way to
lower the recidivism rate
is for people to get
to know who we are.
We're not a product
of our land--
of our environments.
We're just products of the
choices that we've made.
Sometimes we didn't
know any better.
I learned everything in life
through trial and error.
I didn't have a dad, or a big
brother, or anybody to show me.
All my parents were there.
I'd been on my own
since I was 13.
So when they would
come in and just
get to know us and see the type
of people who we are and not
the crime that we committed, it
made them look at us different.
So if you guys want to lower
the recidivism rate in Colorado,
get to know some criminals
who want to change.
Be volunteers.
Go up and speak with the
people at the Defy events.
Even if it's just one
time, I guarantee you
it's everybody wants to change.
Everybody wants to change.
For the most part, a lot of
people just don't know how.
BOB OMER: I think that's--
looking at the
clock, I want to make
sure we leave enough time
for question and answers.
So try to drive
towards a wrap up.
But I think, Ronnie, that's
a perfect segue to what I'd
like for the final
question to be
is what can the community do to
solve this issue of recidivism,
and in a more finite level to
support what's happening here
in the State of Colorado?
And I guess Travis, I'd like
to start with you because I
think your perspective--
you've seen it coming
back to your brother,
but you're also an
entrepreneur yourself.
And so I think it's an
interesting perspective
of saying, what can people
in the community do?
TRAVIS TAYLOR: So I'm glad
I was asked that question.
Indulge me for a second.
Everybody in this room, put
your hands up like this.
Just keep them up
there for a second.
Think about this.
Imagine you just
walked out of prison,
and you just applied for
a job, and they told you
they're going to call
you back, and this
is the ninth time
today someone said
they're going to call you back.
And your probation officer's
calling you asking you
why you don't have a job.
Your kid's mom or dad
is screaming at you
about not paying your bills.
You're living with your
family, and they're
telling you how you're
a loser, and how
you're not going to work.
And then you're turning
around, and you're
looking at the world, and
how does the world see you?
With your hands up, right?
You're vulnerable right now.
Your hands are up because it
shows that you're giving up.
If we don't work together
to change our society
and help Defy, this is
how we will be someday.
Our hands are going to be up.
And there's going to be someone
at the business end of a hand
gun or a knife,
and they're going
to be trying to take what
we worked so hard to get
because they felt like
this that morning,
and they got sick of it.
We as a society need to get
sick of people walking around
with their hands in the air.
We have to decide that
we, as a community,
can work together to
bring our hands down.
This is not about a handout.
This is about a hand up.
It's about you
being in a position
to change someone else's
life with something
as simple as your time, simply
listening to someone's story
and saying, hey, I can't
promise you that you're going
to get a job at Google, right?
I can't promise you that you'll
be a millionaire in five years.
But you know what
I can do for you?
I can help you make
a better decision
so that you and I aren't
talking inside of a prison.
That's what you can do.
You can write a check,
that's true, too.
You can-- I can just simply
pay the problem away, right?
And you can leave it on the
shoulders of Izzy, and Stacey,
and Bob, and the correctional
folks here to take the money
and try to do some good with it.
That works, too.
But is that a solution
to a long-term problem?
You guys deal with code and
complex algorithms every day.
I know, I pay y'all.
With Google AdWords,
I pay you for that.
And you guys work--
you're very welcome.
I paid for all of this,
just so you know--
just so you know.
Discount brother, hear me.
But imagine how complex
it is not having this.
I'm not trying to guilt
you into anything.
I'm trying to get you to step
back and say, we, as a society,
have to decide when
enough is enough.
5% of the world's
population, yet 20% of them
are incarcerated?
We've turned punishment
into a business.
And business is good.
Is this who we are?
We define who we are by
simply taking an opportunity
to reach out to somebody
else, if it's just
your time, if you're more
comfortable with the money,
if you're more comfortable
with a mentorship.
All of this is needed by Defy.
Each one of you in this room
have the power to do something,
no matter how small
you think it is.
And all I'm asking
you as somebody
whose brother was blessed enough
to be part of this, please.
I'm asking for my brother,
for my mother, my father,
and for every person
that is not here, please.
You can change our lives.
And all we're asking is please.
I have nothing to say.
BOB OMER: We're going
to end it right there.
That was incredibly
well said Travis.
Thank you very much.
Let's give our panelists
a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
And I think now we'll open it up
to questions from the audience.
Anybody have a question?
AUDIENCE: I was
just wondering, you
talked a little bit about
what some of the roles
that volunteers have.
But I was curious
if you could give
a little more of an idea
of what kinds of roles
and opportunities there are
in terms of volunteering,
and what you would
do in those roles.
BOB OMER: Sure.
STACEY PUTKA: Do you
want me to answer?
BOB OMER: Yeah, why
don't you take that one.
STACEY PUTKA: Sure.
So volunteers have
several opportunities
to come into the
facilities with us.
We have three big
events throughout
the eight-month program
that focused mostly
on empathy building and
coaching on deliverables
that they all create as
a result of the program.
So those are-- we have a
one-to-one ratio those days.
So if we have 40 EITs, we'd
have 40 volunteers come in.
And if I was your EIT, I
would show you my resume,
and you would give
me coaching on how
to better craft my resume.
So those days are
very structured,
and everyone's getting feedback
on the same deliverables.
Then we have our weekly
classroom sessions,
which are every Tuesday at both
Arkansas Valley Correctional
Facility and Colorado
State Penitentiary.
They're two and 1/2 hours long,
and people come in and go over
a variety of different topics.
I always have
volunteers say to me,
I'd like to come in
and observe a class.
There's no such thing.
You get thrown right
into it and have
some of the most impactful,
very cool conversations.
The other is with
our alumni groups.
So specifically, if we talk
about Travis' brother, Darius,
we have a lot of the guys
who have longer or even life
sentences who graduated
from our first cohort,
but are still very committed
to change and transformation.
So we've put together
an alumni program
where we continue to
provide them kind of like--
think of it as like
elective courses,
where if you guys wanted to
put together a presentation
to show them, I would set
up the day and the time.
And I would call Bob and
ask him to get me a room.
And we'd bring all the alumni
in, bring in the volunteers,
and create something new,
which UZU Media actually
did for us, Travis' company
TRAVIS TAYLOR: Gil Datz'
company, right there.
STACEY PUTKA: Gil's--
Gil and Travis.
BOB OMER: I think the
other part, because we've
talked primarily today
about the in-prison program,
obviously Stacey hit on
that inside-out model.
But the aspect of
the outside piece
is the post-release program.
And graduates who are coming
back out into the community,
Ronnie being one, and having--
starting to run
corporate workshops,
starting to run mentorships
in the community
to continue on that path of
assisting on entrepreneurship
path, assisting on life
skills, and that sort of thing.
And so it's certainly
largely in prison right now.
But also out in the
community, there
is a variety of
opportunities as well.
TOM WYMAN: Bob, can I
just jump in real quick.
BOB OMER: Yeah.
TOM WYMAN: I would just say, if
you're wondering whether you're
qualified to help, or you
would be good to help,
if this resonated
with you at all,
then you're totally qualified,
and you will be really good.
And you will think of it maybe
as going in for a volunteer
opportunity, and you giving.
But I promise you, you
will get so much more back.
And I know that's
trite, and it's cliche,
but I probably spend four
or five days after prison
just processing, just processing
all the conversations I've had,
processing what I've learned
about people, processing--
putting my life in sort of
a different perspective.
Yeah, it's a great deal.
You should jump on it.
BOB OMER: That's an
interesting point.
I just want to jump back in.
Because we have as a program--
we have two
requirements for anybody
who wants to come into
our program or prison,
and we have two requirements
for any volunteer.
And anybody who wants to
come into our program, when
we go into a new prison,
I stand in front of them,
and I say we don't
work with criminals,
we work with people who
have done some bad stuff.
And we don't work with slackers.
And if you meet
both of those boxes,
then you're welcome to
come into the program.
And for volunteers, the numerous
that I meet and talk to,
there's only two requirements.
One is showing up.
Showing up's half
the ballgame here.
And the other thing is coming
in with an open mindset.
And I think it's back
to your point, Tom.
If you're willing to come
in with that open mindset,
that's where the
interaction takes over.
RONNIE MADRID: Can I just
say something real quick?
About coming in, we're
all human beings,
so we relate to each
other in different ways.
It's not about being poor,
or rich, or whatever.
It's about being a human being.
You never know who
you're going to run into,
who one word to actually
change your perspective.
I come from the streets.
And my life was on the curb
selling dope or doing whatever.
And with Defy and the
path that I was taking,
they absolutely helped me
stand on that same curb,
just like this,
from the streets,
looking at the streets,
and say, hey, turn around.
And when I turned around, I
seen the rest of the world.
And I want to be a part of that.
And maybe somebody who you talk
to in prison or whatever you
guys could do, you
guys might just
be the one to change that
one person who nobody thought
would be changed
and let them see
the rest of the world
from that same curb.
That's the best thing
you guys can do.
BOB OMER: That's great.
I think we had a
question over here.
AUDIENCE: Your courage,
your empathy are tremendous.
And I feel it.
And I think most in
this room feel it.
I think people
who work at Google
tend to have that in there.
It is part of our
hiring criteria.
There's a Google in
its hiring criteria
that we often go through.
And we can sense that
empathy in others as well.
That said, what I
wanted to ask really
is, how many of your
graduates of the program
actually come back
and volunteer then?
I'm very curious about that.
And also, Trevor was it?
TRAVIS TAYLOR: Who me?
I'm Travis.
AUDIENCE: Travis?
TRAVIS TAYLOR: Yeah,
yeah I can be Trevor
if you give me a
discount on AdWords.
AUDIENCE: Brother, I got your--
I got your AdWords
optimization all ready for you.
So I can help you with that.
BOB OMER: Yeah.
[TRAVIS CLAPS]
On the first question,
I'll jump in on that.
So in Nebraska and in
California, other Defy states,
there's actually EITs that
work for those chapters that
have come back.
So that's taking volunteering
to the utmost level
from that standpoint.
Here in Colorado,
Ronnie came with us.
We did a radio show
a couple of weeks
ago when Ronnie was with us.
Two weeks ago, we
made a presentation
to about 150 people in the
community corrections industry
in Colorado.
And we brought another one of
our graduates, Damien, with us.
And Brandon and Bob could
talk about this more,
but this was all people
who run the community
corrections across Colorado--
the halfway houses,
the other facilities.
And they came up
to us afterwards,
and they said, we've never
had somebody come back in
and present.
And they just
couldn't believe it.
They were just
baffled by the fact
that Damien was
willing to come in,
and was willing to stand
up there, and be part
of our presentation,
and do the Q&A.
And so for us, that's a key
tenet of the overall program
is to continue to
pay it forward.
I had one final one if we
have time that's there.
I'd like-- Ron put you
on the spot a little bit,
but we talked about one of the
tenants of the Defy Ventures
Colorado program is
business ideation.
You have to develop a business.
You have to pitch a business.
In fact, it's a
requirement to graduate
to pitch a for-profit business
at a formal business pitch
competition.
What was your business idea?
And tell us a
little bit about it.
RONNIE MADRID: My business
idea was a taco truck.
I know, it's--
Denver is saturated with them.
But when I talk with Taco
truck is Yummy Yum-Yums.
I feel like the
name alone is going
to be catchy enough to go
along with the quality of food
that I'm going to produce.
It's going to be authentic Latin
cuisine, [SPEAKING SPANISH]
tacos [SPEAKING SPANISH],,
tacos de lengua,
real authentic Mexican food,
Latin food with a drink
and some chips or whatever.
It's going to cost
me about $7,300
to purchase a used car,
two grills, a freezer.
I have this idea that I'm
going to candy paint it up,
make it appealing to the eye.
I want to park it--
I'm going to focus on the
nightlife in downtown Denver
because you know when
everybody gets out of the clubs
or from going out,
everybody wants
to go and get something to eat.
And everybody's trying to
get pushed out of the clubs.
And people want to
interact with each other
and figure out
what's going on next.
So I have this vision
of a Yummy Yum-Yum truck
with some really good food on
the grill with some music still
playing to kind of keep it
going a little bit afterwards.
And my plates are going
to be like anywhere
between like $8
and $11 per plate
of like three to five tacos
depending on what you get.
Drinks are going to be
like $1.50, $2 extra.
$7,300 hours is the truck--
or excuse me, the trailer,
first month's inventory,
licensing, and permits.
And the paint job parts
to get it screen wrapped.
And the employees,
my employees will--
I will pay them just $100 a day.
They'll have to pay
their own taxes.
But, yeah coming soon,
actually next summer.
I get out of the halfway
house this summer.
So I'm going to
have a whole year
to work on saving the $7,300.
And I plan on launching
Cinco de Mayo next year.
I'll have my first
Yummy Yum-Yum truck.
It's going to be official.
I'm going to do merchandising,
everything, Yummy Yum-Yum
shirts, everything.
Because when you guys
are hungry and stuff,
you guys are thinking
about what to eat,
you're going to be like,
what should we eat?
You want Mexican?
Oh yum, Yummy Yum-Yums.
And we have these tacos.
BOB OMER: So there we go if.
We have anybody in the audience
or anybody watching who
has restaurant
experience and wants
to work with Ron
on helping him get
his business off the ground,
you know where to come to.
So I think we'll
end right there.
I want to thank our panelists
once again for coming up
here and doing this.
[APPLAUSE]
And I want to say on
behalf of everybody
at Defy Ventures Colorado,
I want to thank Google,
in particular, I
want to thank Jess
for giving this opportunity
to come in and tell you
a little bit about
the work we do,
the work we're very
passionate about.
And we're incredibly grateful
that you had us here today.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]